one two three
[Applause]
heck I'm not going to talk today about
the damage recently inflicted upon the
puffs instead we're gonna talk about
video volunteers YouTube has launched
this awesome program that allows all of
us to help out charities we like by
making videos for them and I have made
my first video volunteer video for the
book Wish Foundation nerdfighters if you
want to join me making video volunteer
videos you can go to youtube.com slash
video volunteers I love making a slash
and now hank without further ado i will
transform into my video volunteers self
hi there my name is John Green and I
write books like this one and this one
and also this one a few years ago I was
at a coffee shop with my friend Maureen
Johnson who also writes books and
together we discovered that when you add
the words in your pants to the end of
book titles those book titles become
funnier for instance Maureen once wrote
a book called the key to the golden
Firebird in your pants
but Maureen's book isn't the only
example of the in your pants rule I mean
check out Flannery O'Connor's everything
that rises must converge in your pants
or the Forgotten man in your pants
there's the man who ate everything in
your pants the Sun Also Rises in your
pants which come to think of it is in
fact what the Sun Also Rises is about a
spot of bother in your pants the
neverending story in your pants John
Updike's classic rabbit at rest in your
pants and then of course there's Andrew
Oz eons funny little monkey in your
pants but sadly there are places in the
world where people do not have access to
in your pants jokes places where people
literally cannot imagine what a pleasure
it would be to have a portable Dorothy
Parker in your pants
I'd be like would you say pants oh
that's a good observation brevity is the
soul of lingerie these places cannot
have in your pants jokes because they
don't have books but full access to the
in your pants phenomenon requires more
than just books you need rights by which
to read them libraries in which to store
them and you also need to make sure that
you're getting the right books to people
because the fact is that the Rodale
guide to composting in your pants while
funny is not as funny as the last good
kiss in your pants and that's where the
book Wish Foundation comes in they go
into refugee camps with thousands of
people that have been displaced by the
conflict in Darfur and they get solar
power reading lights and glasses
the right books to people who need them
and right now they're raising money to
build a much needed library and the best
part about the book Wish Foundation is
that they don't send just any book to
these refugee camps they carefully work
with people in the camps to make sure
that all of the books going there are
the best possible in your pants jokes No
what's that no they base it on what
people need and want oh yeah that's good
too
obviously displaced people in refugee
camps have a lot of needs but what the
book Wish Foundation has learned is that
when you go to these refugee camps one
of the things that people say they want
a need is books not only because books
can be entertaining but also because
they can be a way to get to university
and most of all so that they can more
fully appreciate the rich and diverse
world of the in your pants joke please
check out the book Wish Foundation at
book--which org and as we say in my
hometown don't forget to be awesome